do you see any way out
you're so young
[Music]
i don't see no way out i ain't trying to
try i feel like [ __ ]
if i leave my try to leave my zeddie it
killed me so
one day i'm gonna wake up
just not right now i'm just leaving the
face like
all right unique unique uh where did you
grow up where are you from originally
i'm from memphis tennessee south memphis
now is sam mephis north memphis
east memphis west memphis but i'm from
samut it's the dirty cell
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents growing up
well no well
my dad he been he'd been he'd been in
you can't stop it my dad he'd been in
prison
my whole life and my mom
she's been in my life out for now
yeah why has mom been in and out of your
life well she had a
a drug a drug addiction and
dad was in prison for what um
dope
and you uh you were raised by who then
well uh my mom lost cuz of me at the
ages
at the age i was seven she lost close to
me to my
aunt her oldest sister she's the baby
like i said she had a drug addiction she
used to beat on those things
so they took us at a young age how was
your childhood
it was rough it was rough
because i wanted my mom in my life i
didn't give
two folks about my daddy because i never
met him so
but i want my mom to be there but you
know she happens
she chose the dope
over her kids so hey i don't hate her
food or nothing like that but
about her not being in my life as a
child and me growing up i had to really
raise myself
so she the streets raised me if you
really want to know
i started horn at a young age
i was 15. i had to do what i had to do
to give me some money
i had my first child i was 25.
no i took that back i was 24. i had my
first daughter
i had my son at the age of
28.
and [ __ ]
and let me take it back when i said the
streets the streets raised me
well i had i ain't have to choose the
street like but [ __ ]
that's all i knew because that's all i
was around you know
so it's me growing up getting beat how
far did you go in school
i made it to 11th grade
[Music]
yeah okay i made it to 11th grade i got
kicked i got kicked out
because i went and did some time
on a aggravated assault
you know i get out
and i started doing xanax i got
headphones xanax
i went from xanax to
heroin i went from heroin to phenol
and when i couldn't get what i wanted
she
i had to go see in my body to get what i
wanted
so i had my first pimp
at the age of 23 it's my daughter
it's my my my daughter's father
yes uh i [ __ ] around
i [ __ ] around out here in mephis and
called the prostitution charge so
i let the [ __ ] talk me into going out
of town to texas
you know you know he told me
like we was on a couple a couple types
[ __ ] but
when we got out of out of memphis she
ain't got no family up there in houston
so the ball game turned
he made me get out there when i want to
get out there because at first [ __ ] i
was just
you know get out there when that got
ready when we needed the money but
this was like everyday thing and if i
had the money i couldn't come in the
house
i was getting beat with bills
i was getting beat out in my head pistol
would
i had to do [ __ ] i didn't want to do you
feel like you were
forced into that relationship yes i was
but i feel like i was young and dumb
and there was no way out at first
it wasn't no way out it's like i was
closed in
like i said i was doing [ __ ] that i
really didn't want to do
robbing stealing from tricks
i ain't got raped trixin took that money
back
pimps and kidnapped me i just been
through mine
so much and today you're still working
with a pen
yes i am and you give him how much of
the money
i give him all the money
yeah because i feel like
growing up and you ain't got your mother
and your life where your parents and
your life to you know raise you to teach
you what's right and what's wrong wrong
i was looking for love in the wrong
places
so she
i started [ __ ] with pimps and you
know what i'm saying
i like it what do you get out of that
arrangement
with the pimp where you're giving away
all your money what do you get in return
well he take care of me you know i ain't
i ain't long for nothing
yeah i ain't want for nothing he gets my
hair done
you know he feed me clothe me house me
all day is he like your boyfriend as
well
yeah well yeah
we we're cause we're gonna get a five
years so yeah
that one called my boyfriend he's my
daddy
do you recall your very first time
picking up a getting picked up by a guy
my very first time yeah first trick
i feed thing i was 15 years old yeah
and i started you know what i'm saying
i'm like [ __ ]
this easy this is a quick money and i
you know what i'm saying i ain't got the
x no [ __ ] for [ __ ] i just get
out here
and do what i got to do and support my
habits
well he supports my habits because i
give him my i turns
i turn all the cash over to him i can't
come in unless i got a thousand dollars
how much a thousand in one night you'll
make a thousand
like i said i can't come in it's
i count thousand dollars so you know
it's it's kind of [ __ ] up at her
so she that might be i said two three
days
yep until i come up all that money
and turn it over to daddy and your
clients are
white black explaining yes
i don't know why i love white guys i
love them
yeah white uh
i don't just deal with black men because
i feel like they fool the [ __ ]
um white
um what you call them people
mexican hispanic expanding like white
hooks
white and x-men i really don't like
dealing with black guys but like
africans
you know you're like what's the
difference between a black like a [ __ ]
i ain't got sam i really did one of them
africans
yeah from overseas who i know got their
loot
that gets me a money from a man away
do you feel safer working with a pimp
than being on your own
yes i do he provides some security yes
he do
like and i feel like said it might sound
crazy like i'm paying for security or
something like that
but there's nothing wrong with it i'm
safe but you're working and i know hang
on let's not happen to me
you're but you're working hard every
night are you saving money for
your future for your do you have kids
yes i am too
and are you raising them no i'm not
who's raising your kids my mom your mom
well my aunt well i call her my mom
so they good if they need some she
calling me it's just
it's just this life i'm living and i
don't want to drag my kids along with me
so
yeah they stand cordova with my mom
and are you saving money for your future
or for anything
no i'm not you're just surviving you're
still using i'm just leaving
you're still surviving you're still
using uh fentanyl yes i am
i've been on female 5 years now how old
are you
i'm 31 31
does this life get you down depressed
sometimes you get down
yes yes i get down
i just had a nervous breakdown because
like i feel
guilty like cause i suppose being my
kids like
and it's just it's like yeah it's hard
like i can't just
break break a loose from this [ __ ] i try
and try [ __ ] take my head around
my head against the wall and
people say to me i was saying you two
breeders will be going through stuff
like that but hey
like i said i'm looking for love in the
wrong places
do you have hope of one of your tricks
saving you and and taking away from this
life
yeah like my regular like one of my
regulars
yeah he he talks to me all the time he
knew about my daddy
and all that right there my zaddy so
he was like you two brutal should be
going through this you know and i'll
take her you went
i'd be having thoughts it didn't cross
my mind several times
like i get
i give my my daddy everything in like
no nothing seems to like i'm trying to
please you and
it's like nothing i i kinda i never
kind of ain't nothing making you happy
so yeah i have thoughts
yeah this my uh my trick [ __ ]
he like ain't got to go through this
you're right i don't but i just that's
just the lifestyle i chose
say it the same but hey [ __ ] happens
yeah i mean this lifestyle it
you know you have guys that find you
attractive and pick you up so it builds
your self-esteem but ultimately i think
this probably destroys your self-esteem
more than anything right
it must yes
yes it does it does destroy myself
self-esteem it's a it's a job to me
it's just i ain't clocking it's just i
ain't clocking in and clocking that i
ain't punching no clock
it's a job to me this is how i'm
surviving that hurt
but but at some point you're selling
your soul almost just to
survive and it that's got to be
oh look at it and sit in my soul like i
said it's
it's this has survived it's how i'm
surviving out here
you see any way out you're so young
[Music]
i don't see no way out i ain't trying to
try
i feel like [ __ ] if i leave my charlie
zeddie he'll kill me so
one day i'm gonna wake up
just not right now i'm just leaving the
fast like
and not that a day don't go back i don't
think about my kids
i talk to them daily make sure they're
good
just being apart from your kids is the
hardest part of this yes
oh yes
do you feel like the environment you
grew up in set you up for
this thing do you feel like a failure
yeah
he's crazy crazy
but me you know i don't give two
folks how much of a fear about me
or what they say about me what really
breaks me down
my kids but this is just the lifestyle i
live like
process she is she's the prostitute you
know she's she's stupid as [ __ ] she's
sitting on her body four [ __ ] and this
dead in the other
you [ __ ] on the outside looking in
my [ __ ] don't know what i've
been through or what i'm going through
and none of them i don't know if i'm
trying to get away from this
they just on the outside looking in it's
plenty
plenty of days and tried to get away
from his head peck my [ __ ]
this [ __ ] caught me in the midst of
trying to leave him
then it beat me unconscious type [ __ ]
so yeah it's scary as [ __ ]
it's it's scary
yes it is
and i just hate you know i got this monk
on my back
this gorilla on my back and it's hard to
shake and
that me saying that it's the dope
it's really the dope
no i tried to get help you know
try and rehab about it
but who introduced you to
to drugs my home girl
when she's not my hunger no mo
but girl i used to [ __ ] behind with
every day and [ __ ] like this
but if i shake this dope that'd be a bad
[ __ ]
because i once was i'm where i'm still
is
but this ain't unique
this ain't me at all
i don't know who this person is
and the guys that pick you up there you
respect them
you like them or you just tolerate them
because i just
oh it's
it's a disgrace it's uh i just you know
deal with them and then like
i had [ __ ] pick me up and
you know i was into it and they read a
trick and how lit
but it's like they made me feel
you know what i'm saying like i'm
somebody
so hey not bad not in me
treat me like like like [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] like this so it's [ __ ]
out here that ain't
you know
and i'm gonna say may love to what made
me feel
you know what i'm saying like i was
somebody instead of treating me like
[ __ ] like you [ __ ] [ __ ] in it
but i'm just doing it like i get my
money up top
i never never take my clothes off
i ain't gonna suck no dick none of it
until they put my money in my hand first
and that keeper whipping on me so hey
you going to kill me i'mma kill you
is it hard for you knowing that everyone
in your life is trying to take advantage
of you your pimp
the tricks everybody in your life seems
to be just
looking to get something from you
and i'm the type of person dick would
give a [ __ ]
shirt out my back but
uh i can i don't know how to see it
i hate like when i put my all
into something and the [ __ ]
treat me like [ __ ]
like you just selfish in you're gonna
get what's coming to you
and once you get what's coming to you
then god gonna open up them doors
where i can run free you know about me
saying running free
i've been able to get away from all this
[ __ ] like my first pyramid the only way
i got away from him
that [ __ ] went to jail and when he went
to jail and did that time
oh i didn't i didn't pick up the phone
for him
i wrote him a letter and let him know
what it was
i don't want to be with you no more you
get that plan with me imma kill you
and i meant that and i ain't gonna lie i
get on my knees
every night and pray to the lord you
know just
um
do girls ever get it away from their
pimps is there any way to do it other
than unless he goes to jail
there's this half fear that's the only
way i can get away
if a [ __ ] go to jail
what was the best time of your life
with my babies raising my babies taking
them
some incredible pizza and see
little cece's chuckie trees
uh poohpa david buster you know
just giving my kids but i never you know
what i'm saying
hey and
it's like it's like it's a psycho my
mama
is like my mama went through this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying my mama got
eight kids six boys and two beers when
we got taken away from our mom
it's like it's like i'm falling in the
same cycle as my mother and
you know i pray to the lord
to change my ways
i feel like i'm being selfish towards my
babies
and i am but it's
not me it's the dog
and she when i ain't got no money i got
to sell my body to get what i want
and that's sad it's sad but she
is life
you ever been in love before yes
anyone know there was no or nothing
he made me quit haunting all that i was
in a real relationship
what happened there
he you know he ended up getting killed
he ended up getting killed
somebody robbed somebody robbed and shot
him in the head
i'm so sorry
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's considering this
this life i don't give a [ __ ] what
nobody
say about you young ladies y'all
beautiful
you know
try to stay in school do the positive
[ __ ] i don't care [ __ ] say
y'all
green cause y'all don't drink a smoke or
none of it
don't if you don't do it please don't do
not turn to
drugs cause drugs can have you doing
[ __ ] that you never thought you would do
in life
so hey with that being said
say no to drugs and
you know cause you beautiful and love
yourself or nobody else will
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
um
going to jail
going to jail taught me a listen
to me listen so the way i moved now i
moved
different from the way i was moving at
first
like i move smooth
don't know don't don't don't nobody
really know what i'm doing because i
ain't just
putting it out there like this like how
i was at first
i ain't putting in no [ __ ] face
i ain't walking the streets
no more none of it i broke off the
internet
yeah do you find the things that your
tricks ask you to do
gets a little riskier
like well not really like that
oh yes
they need to get out for the sake
because long as long as they pan
i'm willing to do any everything but
[ __ ] without a rubber this it
cause i love my [ __ ] i love my
i love
my life where i look i love my health
and i ain't trying to catch no
[ __ ] a's or nothing like this
so
i don't give a [ __ ] you raise the price
to a thousand dollars i'm not gonna [ __ ]
you without a rubber
unless i see some paperwork on you
and that i i'll show you some paperwork
on me or she you can go to the doctor
with me if you if you believe the
paperwork
fake or anything but there's one thing
this
the number one rule never [ __ ] without
a condom yes sir
um
so tell me about the tattoo on your over
your brow on your forehead
it says nick who is nick
it's my zaddy your pimp
yeah and that was it
it's stupid but
i wanted to show him how much i loved
him so
i put to be i put his name in my
in my face he got mines on his neck he
went getting in his face but
because he said he didn't want to miss
his face but
a year later you got two tattoos
over your ab brad your mama name and
your father he's deceased but you said
you'll never get a tattoo on your face
all right unique thank you so much for
sharing your story
and i wish you the best of luck getting
out of this
me life i wish myself the best of luck
can i help
thank you
you